Well, gentlemen, it is
now down to the two of you
guys to battle it out for
the title of "Forged in Fire"
champion.
And so congratulations.
In this final round, we're
going to be sending you guys
back home to build an
iconic weapon from history.
And that weapon is--
the Dahomey machete.
MAN (VOICEOVER):
This lethal machete
was once wielded by the
legendary all-female army
in Western Africa known
as the Dahomey Amazons.
The long, slightly curved
blade flared out to a wide tip,
giving the female
warriors the ability
to deliver fatal blows that cut
cleanly through bone and flesh
in a single blow.
These skilled women warriors
were an elite fighting force
and extremely intimidating,
often carrying trophies
of their fallen enemies.
The machetes were
a powerful weapon
designed to cleave through
anything that got in their way.
Today, the Dahomey machete can
be seen wielded in the 2020 HBO
series, "Lovecraft Country."
GRADY POWELL: You guys
will have four days
to work on your
blades, because I
want you to both bring us back
a blade worth at least $10,000.
We'll see you guys in four days.
All right.
All right, good luck, man.
My name is Alex Morris.
I'm 48 years old.
I'm from Warwick, Rhode Island.
What I like most about
bladesmithing is it's
challenging.
And I believe that if we
don't challenge ourselves,
we don't grow.
I'm super excited to
get after this thing.
And in goes the steel.
The biggest challenge
will be drawing
out the end of the blade.
This is new for me.
I'm-- probably going to take
me a while to figure out how
I'm going to move
this steel, to get
it to where I want it to go.
Yeah, I'm liking it.
It's getting there.
I want to make
Damascus and build it
for the two disc-shaped
guards and hopefully
heat-treat my blade.
Gonna stick some weld on there.
And I'm going to get it in
the forge after I quench.
Yeah, yeah, it's looking good.
Think we're good!
I think my blade is
coming out pretty well.
Right now, I'm cleaning
up my Damascus.
If none of the knives
break out there,
they're going to start
looking at those things.
The Damascus will help my
blade stand out against Adam's.
Ah, it broke in half.
The last forge weld I did last
night must not have taken.
So I'm going to scrap it,
just use regular mono steel.
Now I'm, like, starting
over completely
on my guards and pommel.
So I wasted a lot of
time doing that Damascus,
and it turned out for nothing.
This is a hard challenge, man.
This is taxing.
Whew!
ADAM: My name is Adam Coonradt,
and I'm a firefighter-paramedic
in the city of Troy, New York.
My wife and my kids
are very supportive,
and like that I do knifemaking.
My two children, they're
both makers as well.
And I couldn't be any
prouder of both of them.
I have never made
anything this big before.
If I win, I'm going
to Disneyland.
I think right now,
my biggest obstacle
is the size of the piece.
This piece of metal is
so thick and so large,
it's taking forever to heat up--
just not moving.
I'm growing impatient.
I think there's
enough steel here,
I can actually cut off a piece.
It's starting to move, but
very nervous about how thin
this blade actually
is starting to become.
I don't want it to
break or shatter.
I put some pressure on it
with the angle grinder.
I ended up doing too much
pressure, and it broke.
My heart sinks.
Now, I have to restart.
There's no way I can send
this in to be tested.
[sigh]
Day four-- final day,
make it or break it.
So yesterday, I definitely
made a comeback.
It's time to assemble.
Now, I started working on
my actual physical handle.
I just don't want to
use a piece of wood.
I want to dress it
up a little bit.
So I twist three
different strands of wire,
so it's going to have
an alternating pattern.
The handle is looking great.
It's better than I imagined.
My kids came downstairs
to check on me.
How's the machete
coming along?
Aw, that's really cool.
- You like that?
- Yeah.
ADAM: Yeah, I can tell
they're proud of me,
sticking it through, and
being able to produce
a tangible item.
It's a proud dad moment.
(DOUG MARCAIDA
VOICE) It will kill.
VOICE) It will kill?
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
I will take your machete and
deliver some lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Alex, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yes, sir.
I'm most concerned about
everything with this test.
I'm not sure it's sharp enough.
I'm not sure it's strong enough.
I don't know what it's
going to do to my blade.
I have no idea.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Alex.
The balance you have
in your blade is nice.
For every cut, I can
really control and feel
like I'm chopping in there.
The edge, no issues at all.
It is still very sharp.
More importantly,
sir, your machete--
it will kill.
Thanks.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Adam, it's time
to have fun with your blade.
Are you ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
I hope my blade doesn't break.
I had a lot of setbacks
making this blade.
You know, I had to start over.
I hope it doesn't come back
to bite me in the butt.
I'm saying a little
prayer-- please don't break,
please don't break,
please don't break.
(WHISPERING) Yes!
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Adam, let's talk
about your weapon here.
This is a very
forward-heavy blade.
But that forward
weight really cuts deep
into this ballistics dummy.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
That's worth it right there.
I can go home now.
[laughs]
All right, gentlemen,
you know what time it is.
It's time for the strength
test-- the shield chop.
What I want to see on top
of how durable your blades
are-- is there effectiveness
against that shield, all right?
So Alex, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
All right, so Alex, obviously,
there's a bit of an issue.
What happened here is you--
you can see the grain size.
It looks like 40
grit sandpaper, which
is really, really large grain.
And then right here,
see that black?
Yeah.
DAVID BAKER: That was a crack.
OK.
So that crack existed
probably during the heat treat.
Once I hit just face onto the
shield, it just cut loose.
GRADY POWELL: Alex,
we hate to see that.
Your blade had a
catastrophic failure,
but you are not out
of the fight just yet.
Your blade broke on
the fourth strike.
So that means, Adam, in order
to become "Forged in Fire"
champion, your Dahomey machete
must survive four strikes.
Are you ready?
Yes.
Everything is riding
on these four strikes.
I need my machete
to hold together.
I've got to make
it through this.
Whew.
GRADY POWELL: Well, Adam, you
survived your four strikes.
So that means you are
the "Forged in Fire"
champion, so congratulations.
Alex, unfortunately, you
didn't win this round.
You crushed it in round
one and round two.
But your time in
the forge has ended.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Thanks.
I'm a little disappointed,
but I'm definitely proud
of the machete that I made.
Making something this big
was quite a challenge,
and it's a learning process.
So I'm definitely glad
I had this opportunity.
I'm glad I got to know
all these other smiths.
This was fun.
It was a blast.
Well, Adam, your blade
survived the four strikes.
It's a beautiful beast.
And it just won you $10,000 and
the title of "Forged in Fire"
champion.
Congratulations, man.
Well done.
Was it everything you
thought it would be?
ADAM: And more.
It's been an honor.
It's been a pleasure.
Wow, what an experience.
It's kind of surreal.
But it's a great feeling.
It's awesome.
My family supported me, so
kids, we're going to Disney.
[music playing]